We are here with the one and only Molly Shannon.
This is how we kick and we do it.
You're so flexible.
I'm so flexible.
I'm so bendy.
You're a really good dancer.
Really?
Yeah, I remember,
I was like "Drew's a really good dancer," yes.
Very good, see?
(applause)
I remember, yeah, I remember.
Well we are animals,
and we gotta get out of the cage.
You're an animal.
You're an animal!
But it's true, I mean I do,
I feel like I'm...
I do like that analogy of the greyhound at the gate,
we did this story about this little wrestling girl,
who's taking on older boys and winning.
And like you should see her pictures,
she's like...
And I'm like "Yes, I love this girl so much!"
That's so cute.
It's so true, I think that life is
an opportunity to just "Huh."
Exactly.
And on that note...
Drew is my mentor
because she was so established in show business
and when we did "Never Been Kissed" together,
I had gotten my movie "Superstar" greenlit,
and we were looking for directors,
and so I had had a meeting with Bruce McCulloch,
who we were pursuing to direct "Superstar"
and I came back to Drew on set,
and I said "Bruce McCulloch passed on the movie,
he's not gonna do it."
And Drew was like "What?
You can't let him pass, wait!"
And I go "No, he came into LA for a meeting,
he's flying back to Toronto."
And Drew goes "No, wait a minute!
You gotta call him back!
You gotta stop his plane! Wait a minute!"
And you gave me this advice.
I go "Well what should I say?"
You go "Ask him what his concerns are,
ask him what he needs to make it work,
does he wanna work less days, what's the problem?
There has to be a solution,
and just tell him you'll give him whatever he wants.
Don't let him get on the plane, call him!"
And you coached me, and I wrote down what to say,
and I called him, and did exactly what you told me,
and then he ended up taking the job.
Yes!
Drew Barrymore.
(applause)
Yeah. That's very you.
I'm so glad we got that story here.
That story is in the book, and it's so true,
what are we all waiting for?
What are we, you talked about not being perfect.
Oh, not being perfect.
And you know, listen,
at a certain point you gotta take the no,
or you're gonna get a restraining order.
But up until that point, until the law steps in,
or until you know in your gut that you've pushed too far
and it's time to back off,
you go to that line!
What are we waiting for?
Go for it!
Yeah, and then
at least you tried,
even if it, yeah, go for it.
(applause)
Now I wanna talk about being busy,
I love, you have a new Showtime show.
You're so hot off the other two, and "White Lotus,"
and I mean, god, it just never ends,
and now you have this Showtime show,
"I Love That For You."
Will you tell us about that?
Absolutely, so this is a show with Vanessa Bayer,
she's hilarious, she created the show with Jeremy Beiler.
Another SNL alum.
SNL alum, and she's also from my hometown, Cleveland,
and so this is about the world of home shopping network,
which is such a fun world to be in,
and my character's the queen salesperson,
and Vanessa's character comes in
and I take her under my wing,
and it's really fun, and the show's really good.
We have a clip.
Yeah, okay, great.
I can ask if someone else can train me,
it's insane that you would train me.
You know what? For you, I'm gonna do it.
I got a lot of great pointers.
And as you know, I'm really good at this.
Welcome to the jungle, Joanne.
It's Joanna.
Oh, Joanna.
And don't you dare take a picture of my butt.
It's so funny.
(applause)
You're the best.
Everybody, if you wanna read one of the most profound,
beautiful books you will ever read in your life,
then you've got to read "Hello, Molly!"
And it is available now in bookstores,
and anywhere you get your books from.
And then you can also catch Molly in "I Love That For You"
premiering April 29th on Showtime.
I can't wait to watch that show.
Oh, good, thank you, Drew.
I watch every wild choice
you make and just...
Thank you.
(applause)
(upbeat music)